Edward R Murrow once said the newest
computer can merely compound at speed
the oldest problem in the relations
between human beings and in the end the
communicator will be confronted with the
old problem of what to say and how to
say it today the Internet has put us all
in touch I think that's one of the big
areas of growth in the future is that as
we get more and more people who have
enough bandwidth to be able to do video
online and the tools begin to mature so
that people can you know remix and and
cut and build things I think we're gonna
see mass collaborative projects from all
around the world I do think this sort of
a general curiosity is it a desire for
information that people have and I think
that also shapes the world wanted to
explore want to know things better
willing to share information wanting to
be in touch the internet gives us all a
voice but what are we saying where can
thinking people be heard that's where
big thing comes in the thing that's
changing the media consumption more than
anything else is the internet rising as
a primary source of news and the fact
that newspapers and other traditional
media broadcast television are taking it
on the chin we have access to so much
information but is it getting any more
informative the news conference has
become a farce much controlled by the
White House tendency to reduce
everything to a soundbite it makes it
almost impossible to for people who have
extended thoughts in graceful language
the system is pretty badly bent if it's
not broken and it is beyond our capacity
as reporters to fix it
Big Think believes it is up to us the
consumer the user the citizen to fix the
system we may not have all the answers
but we all seem to have the questions as
we speak right now one tip of young
black males in America and prison parole
or probation in this great nation why
the real question is whether China wants
to join the United States on the world
stage
well I can't we become civilized are we
crazy imperialists have we been insanely
racist have we committed genocide have
we bombed civilian populations yes yes
yes and yes but in a fallen world have
we ultimately been a force for good what
is the gap between understanding and
action and what does it take to bridge
that gap in a global world all
information is about you how you react
to it how it feeds your opinions or
changes your mind how you share it with
others while today's technology gives us
all a voice it also challenges us to
listen and respond I think there needs
to become the idea of the global citizen
global leader that they're really
concerned about the global problems of
the world is everybody's responsibility
pretty cold weather is crucial but
includes everything is just absolutely
fundamental to a process you have to be
prepared to change your mind at all
times there are more and more people
coming up and attacking reason and
saying that's not the case I've seen all
kinds of people but I've also seen all
kinds of people who never see all kinds
of people and they're all cliches are
the things that I think work are our
first that people become interested to
be interested in problems that aren't
just related to your work and become
interested as a member of a community
and something a little bit broader big
think wants this to be your big moment
what will you say
it's just ludicrous for journalists to
say I don't have an opinion we're all
dripping with opinion in a way I can't
help but believe in God despite all the
evidence to the contrary which makes me
very angry at God there is a negative
correlation between how religious the
country is and what its per capita
income is without addressing poverty i
have long advocated dialog with syria
and dialogue with Iran I've never seen a
point where we're as anxious we have
nuclear proliferation right back on the
front burner I think we're headed
towards on you know 20 30 years of
incredible chaos and turmoil I think
technology could be quite relevant to
our happiness globally we should be all
creating the critical mass of
consciousness that says that everybody's
problems are our problems and that we
have the ability to collectively change
the world this is one place where
technology can help what can I do how
can I help well the answer is loved